- What's going on, guys?
Eddie "Truck" Gordon,
UFC Season 19 Ultimate Fighter Champion
Capoeira Pro Fighter.
- Johnathan Cepeda, 17 and two,
15 knockouts as a professional boxer.
Three time Golden Gloves Champion.
Everything in the amateurs I won
and I'm here for you.
(bass music)
- To be quite honest man,
I was not expecting much
from this fight.
You figure Logan Paul
has a zero pro fights,
zero boxing matches.
KSI had a little more experience.
He had one fight coming
in so I was expecting
sloppy, haymakers just
swinging for the fences,
no rig, general ship.
- It's either gonna be super boring
or super entertaining
because boxers nowadays
like they box.
So the art of boxing
is hit and not get hit.
Like a Floyd Mayweather.
Everybody hates that because
they're running around
and when you don't know how to box,
it's literally two bulls
just charging each other.
- Before I saw the fight,
I thought KSI is gonna win
just because--
- I agree.
- He had more fight experience.
- When I found out that
Logan hasn't fought before
in front of people, like
I said it's so different.
It is extremely different
when the adrenaline.
I gave the edge to KSI because he went
through that experience already.
- I tell you what, man.
I was impressed with
a lot with this fight.
What I saw blew me away
because I saw somebody
that was comfortable in the ring.
I saw somebody that was
living off the moment
like a veteran so that to me,
alone, was pretty awesome.
First, KSI's movement.
His head movement was really good.
It kinda reminded me of Mike Tyson.
Slipping left, slipping right.
- I think if they would
have actually threw
a few left hooks, because
they were just throwing
like a one-two with the haymakers,
I believe that Logan
could have stopped KSI
with a bit more training
and just more executing
more technique with the left hook.
I'm a left hooker,
so that's my favorite
punch out of 15 knockouts,
13 of my knockouts, all
of them by left hook.
Logan had a real good jab.
So if he would have used
it a little bit more
to double it up, throw
the cross and follow up
with the left hook, I believe
he could have stopped him.
My opinion, Logan won the fight.
- Towards the end of the
fight, I think KSI started
to turn it on a little bit more.
Maybe his conditioning
was a little bit better
since he had that previous fight.
Logan Paul has a bigger frame than KSI.
So no doubt in my mind if he had to cut
a little more weight, that's gonna affect
his cardio, it's gonna
affect how much punches
he could absorb and that's why I feel like
if the fight went on a little bit longer,
KSI had a great opportunity
to finish that fight.
Because when you lose
weight, when you cut weight,
that actual fluid around
your brain gets depleted
as well.
Do I agree with the draw?
I can see where they
came up with the draw.
Logan edged it out by winning
the couple early rounds.
I feel if it was one or two more rounds,
that KSI had a chance to--
- Would have stopped him.
- Finish the fight.
He would have stopped him.
Based off their reaction
at the end of the fight,
they both looked pissed.
I don't think it was rigged.
- I would never want a draw.
- I want to either win or lose.
- I wouldn't want a draw.
- I can't sleep with a draw.
- Jake and Deji, it was
basically a slaughterhouse.
Jake had extreme composure.
If he would have just came
around with the left hook,
I think he would have put him down.
- He looked like a natural.
He looked like he wanted to be in there.
- Yes.
- He looked like he trained for the fight.
He was the aggressor, he was the predator.
I feel like Deji was the prey.
- Deji, come train with me.
I got you.
- In conclusion, I think
that was awesome, man.
KSI and Jake, Logan, all you
guys laid it out on the line.
If you want to get another
fight, come holler at me.
Come holler at my boy.
We gonna get you guys right.
We're here for you.
(rock music)
- Hey, Unsolved is on a new channel.
And now your part.
Subscribe here.
- Subscribe here.
That was my part.